selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah direktur teknis
pendidikan di IBM Quantum. Ini adalah pelajaran ke-n dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran terakhir dalam
unit kedua dari seri yang membahas tentang algoritma kuantum. Kita sudah membicarakan model query dari komputasi termasuk
algoritma kuantum yang menawarkan keunggulan yang dapat dibuktikan atas algoritma klasik dalam model tersebut. Kita sudah mendiskusikan konsep-konsep fundamental yang terhubung dengan
algoritma kuantum dan bagaimana kita bisa mengukur biaya komputasi, dan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita mendiskusikan estimasi fase dan algoritma Shor.
Dalam pelajaran ini kita akan mendiskusikan algoritma Grover yang memberikan keunggulan kuadrat dari kuantum atas
algoritma klasik untuk masalah pencarian tak terstruktur yang disebut unstructured search problems, yang akan saya deskripsikan setelah kita masuk ke
pelajaran. Ini semua adalah topik-topik fundamental mengenai algoritma kuantum. Ada juga algoritma kuantum
lainnya serta paradigma umum yang menyatukan berbagai algoritma kuantum dan teknik algoritma kuantum, dan
kalau kamu tertarik saya mendorong kamu untuk melihat Quantum Algorithm Zoo yang mengkategorikan algoritma kuantum yang diketahui dan menyertakan banyak referensi
ke makalah penelitian asli yang berkontribusi pada pengembangannya. Untuk seri ini,
kita hanya akan berpegang pada hal-hal fundamental dan dimulai dari pelajaran berikutnya kita akan beralih ke topik baru. Tapi
pertama mari kita bicara tentang algoritma Grover. Berikut gambaran umum pelajaran. Kita akan mulai dengan diskusi singkat tentang
masalah komputasi yang akan kita tangani sepanjang pelajaran, yaitu unstructured search. Secara intuitif kamu bisa
memikirkan masalah unstructured search sebagai pencarian melalui kumpulan item yang tidak diurutkan dan belum diatur dengan cara yang berguna.
Kemudian kita akan mendiskusikan algoritma Grover yang merupakan algoritma kuantum yang menawarkan keunggulan kuadrat atas
algoritma klasik, dan kita akan segera membahas apa artinya itu secara tepat. Deskripsi sangat tingkat tinggi dari
cara kerja algoritma ini adalah: pertama ada langkah inisialisasi, dan kemudian operasi yang akan saya sebut sebagai operasi
Grover diiterasi beberapa kali, dan kemudian akhirnya sebuah pengukuran dilakukan yang mengungkapkan kandidat
solusi untuk masalah pencarian. Saya akan menjelaskan apa operasi Grover itu dan bagaimana ia bisa
diimplementasikan pada komputer kuantum, dan kemudian kita akan menjalani analisis dari operasi ini untuk lebih memahami apa yang dilakukannya dan mengapa berguna untuk
pencarian. Bagian ketiga dari pelajaran ini berkaitan dengan jumlah iterasi
dalam algoritma Grover, atau dengan kata lain berapa kali operasi Grover harus diterapkan dengan asumsi bahwa kita ingin
memaksimalkan kemungkinan algoritma berhasil menemukan apapun yang kita cari sambil sekaligus meminimalkan
biayanya. Kita akan mulai dengan masalah unique search yang merupakan kasus khusus di mana ada tepat satu solusi untuk
masalah pencarian kita, dan kemudian kita akan mempertimbangkan apa yang terjadi ketika ada beberapa solusi. Dan akhirnya saya akan menyimpulkan
pelajaran dengan beberapa catatan singkat tentang algoritma Grover dan generalisasinya. Mari kita mulai dengan
masalah komputasi yang akan kita tangani sepanjang pelajaran. Pertama, seperti yang sering kita lakukan, kita
akan menggunakan Sigma untuk menunjukkan alfabet biner dan kita akan menggunakan notasi ini untuk keseluruhan pelajaran jadi saya tidak akan terus
mengingatkan kamu. Misalkan kita punya sebuah fungsi f yang memetakan string biner dengan panjang tertentu n ke
alfabet biner. Asumsi kita adalah bahwa kita bisa dengan mudah mengevaluasi fungsi ini untuk
contoh, mungkin kita punya sirkuit Boolean untuk fungsi ini yang ukurannya polinomial dalam n. Sekarang ini tidak berarti bahwa ini adalah
fungsi yang sederhana dalam arti apapun atau bahwa kita punya pemahaman yang sangat baik tentang fungsi ini. Misalnya, mungkin kita punya
sirkuit Boolean yang cukup rumit dan berantakan untuk menghitung f yang memungkinkan kita mengevaluasinya pada string input yang berbeda tetapi tidak harus memiliki bentuk yang
bagus yang dirancang untuk memudahkan hidup kita. Tujuan kita adalah menemukan solusi yang
berarti string biner dengan panjang n yang menyebabkan f mengevaluasi ke satu. Secara umum ini adalah masalah komputasi yang sangat sulit
atau setidaknya kita menduga itu sangat sulit. Khususnya kalau input-nya sebenarnya adalah deskripsi
dari sirkuit Boolean untuk menghitung fungsi f, maka ini adalah masalah yang disebut NP-complete. Satu cara
kita bisa memformalkan masalah ini adalah sebagai masalah query, dan memang untuk keperluan pelajaran ini cukup masuk akal
untuk memikirkan masalah ini murni dalam konteks model query. Tapi ketika kita berpikir tentang di mana atau kapan masalah ini
mungkin muncul dalam praktik, lebih alami untuk memikirkan f sebagai yang dihitung oleh sirkuit Boolean.
Seperti yang kita lihat di pelajaran enam, kita bisa menghubungkan dua sudut pandang ini melalui konstruksi yang kita jalani untuk mengambil sirkuit Boolean dan
mengkonversinya menjadi quantum circuit untuk mengimplementasikan operasi query atau gate query. Bagaimanapun juga, secara konseptual
input untuk masalah ini adalah fungsi f ini dan kita mencari solusi kalau ada. Dan kalau
tidak ada solusi, yang berarti f ternyata adalah fungsi konstanta nol, maka output yang benar adalah melaporkan
bahwa tidak ada solusi. Ini adalah masalah unstructured search dalam artian tidak ada
yang istimewa tentang f yang memudahkan pencarian solusi. Ini tidak seperti kita sedang mencari
melalui data yang sudah diurutkan atau yang telah dimuat ke dalam struktur data semacam itu yang memfasilitasi pencarian, dan tidak ada janji pada
fungsi f yang mungkin membantu kita. Satu cara untuk memikirkan ini adalah bahwa ini seperti mencari nomor telepon tertentu
di buku telepon sebagai lawan dari mencari nama yang jauh lebih mudah dengan asumsi bahwa namanya sudah
diurutkan secara alfabetis. Dalam istilah praktis, ini bukan benar-benar tentang mencari melalui data
yang cenderung kita atur dan simpan dengan cara yang memudahkan pencarian. Ini lebih representatif dari mencari
solusi untuk persamaan yang rumit misalnya, atau mungkin mencari kombinasi yang membuka
gembok. Sebagai catatan sampingan, masuk akal untuk memikirkan masalah ini dalam konteks model query terlepas dari bagaimana kita mungkin
merasakan relevansi praktis dari model itu. Tentu saja tidak ada oracle atau kotak hitam dalam kehidupan nyata, tapi sampai kita
mengetahui sebaliknya, sirkuit Boolean yang rumit dan misterius semacam kotak
hitam. Sekarang mari kita pikirkan tentang algoritma untuk memecahkan masalah unstructured search ini dan kita akan melakukan ini
dalam model query hanya untuk kesederhanaan. Kalau kita punya sirkuit Boolean untuk fungsi kita daripada kotak hitam,
maka kita masih bisa menjalankan algoritma query padanya. Tapi tentu saja kita tidak bisa mengecualikan kemungkinan bahwa beberapa algoritma baru
ditemukan untuk masalah ini yang tidak berdasarkan membuat query, tapi kita tidak akan mempedulikan
kemungkinan itu. Pertama, sedikit notasi: total jumlah string input ke fungsi f adalah 2 pangkat
WEBVTT
n kecil di mana n kecil adalah panjang dari string input ke f. Dan mulai sekarang saya akan membiarkan N besar menjadi angka ini, 2 pangkat
n kecil. Cukup umum orang menggunakan huruf kapital seperti ini untuk menunjukkan dua pangkat versi huruf kecil
dari huruf itu. Kita akan banyak membicarakan tentang N kapital jadi ini hanya akan
memudahkan dan membantu menjaga segalanya sedikit lebih rapi. Dan sekali lagi notasi ini berlaku untuk
seluruh pelajaran. Tentu saja kita bisa memecahkan masalah pencarian secara klasik dengan hanya
mengiterasi melalui semua kemungkinan string n bit dalam urutan apapun yang kita pilih, mengevaluasi f pada setiap satu
dari mereka. Kalau kita menemukan solusi di titik manapun kita bisa berhenti, tapi dalam kasus terburuk kita akan berakhir mengevaluasi f pada setiap string input
tunggal. Jadi ini memerlukan n — yang berarti N kapital —
query. Kita bisa memilih untuk mengukur biaya komputasi ini dengan cara yang berbeda, bukan hanya dalam hal jumlah query tapi jumlah query
merepresentasikan berapa kali kita harus mengevaluasi fungsi f, dan wajar untuk mengharapkan bahwa evaluasi-evaluasi f akan mendominasi biaya
dari komputasi ini. Ini sebenarnya adalah yang terbaik yang bisa kita lakukan dengan algoritma deterministik,
dan sekali lagi ini dalam konteks model query. Kalau kita sudah melakukan query pada setiap string input
kecuali satu, dan f telah mengambil nilai nol pada semuanya sejauh ini, bagaimana kita bisa yakin bahwa string terakhir
bukan solusi? Jawabannya adalah kita tidak bisa, jadi kita memang butuh semua n query dalam kasus
terburuk. Kita juga bisa menggunakan keacakan yang bisa menawarkan beberapa peningkatan yang sangat kecil seperti mengurangi
jumlah query yang diharapkan yang dibutuhkan untuk menemukan solusi ketika ada satu, atau kita bisa secara efektif menukar probabilitas kebenaran
dengan pengurangan dalam query. Tapi bagaimanapun kamu mengirisnya, kita masih akan membutuhkan jumlah query yang linear
dalam n. Jadi secara klasik kita membutuhkan jumlah query linear, yang berarti linear
dalam N kapital. Algoritma Grover adalah algoritma kuantum untuk pencarian yang lebih baik. Ia hanya memerlukan O besar dari
akar kuadrat dari n query. Query-query itu terjadi dalam superposisi jadi ini bukanlah sihir, tapi
ini adalah peningkatan yang signifikan atas apa yang mungkin secara klasik, dan inilah yang dimaksud dengan keunggulan
kuadrat. Bisakah keunggulan kuadrat kuantum atas klasik ini diubah menjadi keunggulan yang nyata dalam arti praktis?
Mungkin tidak dalam waktu dekat, tapi di masa depan yang jauh siapa yang tahu. Tapi bahkan kalau
algoritma Grover tidak pernah mengarah pada keunggulan praktis untuk pencarian, ini tetap merupakan bagian penting dari
fondasi algoritma kuantum yang sangat layak dipahami. Sebelum kita beralih ke algoritma Grover sendiri, kita perlu
membicarakan sebentar tentang yang disebut phase query gate. Banyak algoritma kuantum dalam model query secara alami diekspresikan
menggunakan phase query gate dan kita akan melihat bahwa algoritma Grover adalah contoh
spesifik. Mari kita mulai dengan tinjauan singkat tentang gate query biasa untuk fungsi f dari
bentuk yang sudah kita bicarakan. Gate query UF didefinisikan pada keadaan basis standar seperti yang ditampilkan di
layar, dan untuk superposisi keadaan basis standar, aksinya ditentukan oleh linearitas. Dan layak untuk mengingatkan
diri kita bahwa dari sirkuit Boolean untuk f kita memang bisa membangun circuit untuk operasi UF ini dengan biaya yang
linear dalam ukuran sirkuit Boolean. Phase query gate untuk f, di sisi lain, yang akan kita sebut
dengan nama ZF, beroperasi seperti ini. Khususnya gate ini beroperasi pada
n qubit kecil sebagai lawan n plus satu qubit kecil, dan pada dasarnya secara otomatis menendang nilai fungsi
ke dalam fase daripada meng-XOR nilai output ke qubit tambahan seperti yang kita lakukan untuk
UF. Jadi kalau kita pikirkan apa yang terjadi ketika kita menggunakan phase kickback pada gate UF,
kita pada dasarnya hanya mengimplementasikan ZF gate. Kita membutuhkan keadaan minus dan biayanya satu
evaluasi dari UF, tapi kita memang mendapatkan kembali keadaan minus dan kita bisa menggunakannya untuk yang berikutnya kalau mau, atau
kita bisa membuangnya. Jadi itulah phase query gate. Sekarang kalau kita hanya
diberi phase query gate ZF dan ini adalah satu-satunya cara kita punya akses ke fungsi f, kita sebenarnya tidak bisa
memulihkan gate UF. Tapi kalau kita punya versi terkontrol dari ZF maka kita bisa
membangun gate UF dan saya tinggalkan yang satu itu untuk kamu sebagai
latihan. Selain phase query gate untuk fungsi f, kita juga akan membutuhkan phase query gate untuk fungsi OR dari n bit
atau dengan kata lain fungsi yang mengambil nilai nol ketika diberi string semua-nol dan sebaliknya mengambil
nilai satu. Dan secara eksplisit cara ZOR bekerja pada keadaan basis standar ditampilkan
di sini di layar. Gate ini tidak memiliki ketergantungan pada fungsi f jadi tidak memerlukan
query apapun, dan satu cara kita bisa membangun quantum circuit yang mengimplementasikan operasi ini adalah dengan melakukan sesuatu
yang mirip dengan apa yang kita lakukan untuk fungsi f kecuali bahwa kita mulai dengan sirkuit Boolean yang menghitung fungsi OR pada
n bit. Dan sekarang kita punya gate-gate ini, kita siap untuk beralih ke bagian
berikutnya. Sekarang kita akan mendiskusikan algoritma Grover, dimulai dengan deskripsi algoritma. Kita mulai dengan menginisialisasi
n qubit kecil masing-masing ke keadaan plus, atau dengan kata lain kita menempatkan qubit-qubit ini ke dalam superposisi yang sama dari semua
string biner dengan panjang n. Yang akan kita lakukan secara efektif adalah mengarahkan keadaan qubit-qubit ini
menuju solusi, jadi intuitif kita memulai dalam keadaan ini karena kita belum tahu apa-apa tentang fungsi f —
pada titik ini setiap string sama-sama mungkin menjadi solusi, dan itu tercermin oleh fakta bahwa qubit-qubit ini berada dalam superposisi yang sama dari semua
string. Kemudian kita mengiterasi — kita berulang kali menerapkan operasi Grover yang benar-benar merupakan inti dari
algoritma, dan saya akan mendeskripsikannya sebentar. Kita menerapkan operasi ini sebanyak T kali di mana T adalah beberapa bilangan bulat non-negatif,
tapi angka ini sebenarnya tidak ditentukan oleh algoritma itu sendiri — kita harus memilih T dengan suatu cara, dan di bagian berikutnya
kita akan membicarakan pilihan yang baik untuk T. Tapi untuk sekarang kita bisa memikirkan jumlah iterasi t ini sebagai
sembarang. Dan akhirnya kita mengukur dalam basis standar dan itu memberi kita
kandidat solusi. Tidak ada jaminan bahwa itu adalah solusi, tapi kalau kita memilih T dengan baik maka
probabilitas untuk mendapatkan solusi bisa dibuat besar. Dan inilah operasi Grover
WEBVTT
itu sendiri yang kita sebut G. Ini adalah komposisi dari operasi-operasi semuanya pada N qubit, jadi ini adalah operasi N
qubit. Pertama kita punya gate ZF, atau dengan kata lain phase query gate untuk
fungsi input f, diikuti oleh lapisan Hadamard gate, dan kemudian kita punya ZOR yang merupakan phase query gate untuk fungsi
OR, dan akhirnya lapisan Hadamard gate lainnya. Jadi kita melihat bahwa satu iterasi dalam
langkah dua bisa diimplementasikan oleh circuit yang memiliki bentuk yang ditampilkan di sini di layar, dan di sini kita punya empat qubit omong-omong,
tapi secara umum kita bisa punya jumlah qubit berapa pun. Hal penting yang perlu dicatat di sini adalah bahwa kita membutuhkan satu query dari f untuk mengimplementasikan G. Kita
membutuhkan satu query untuk mengimplementasikan ZF dan tidak ada operasi lain yang memiliki ketergantungan pada f sehingga mereka tidak memerlukan query apapun. Jadi angka T yang
merepresentasikan berapa kali kita menerapkan G pada langkah dua juga merepresentasikan jumlah query yang
kita butuhkan. Berikut cara umum yang mungkin kita gunakan algoritma Grover, tapi ini tentu bukan satu-satunya cara. Seperti yang saya katakan
sebelumnya, hal pertama yang perlu kita lakukan adalah memilih T dan kita akan masuk ke itu di bagian berikutnya.
Untuk T yang kita pilih, kita menjalankan algoritma Grover untuk T iterasi dan kita mendapatkan kandidat solusi
x. Tidak ada jaminan bahwa x benar-benar merupakan solusi, tapi kita bisa menghabiskan satu query tambahan untuk memeriksa. Kalau kita punya solusi, maka kita bisa
mengeluarkan solusi itu dan berhenti. Dan sebaliknya kita bisa mencoba lagi, mungkin dengan pilihan T yang berbeda
tapi tidak harus, atau kita bisa menyerah dan melaporkan bahwa tidak ada solusi. Seperti yang saya katakan sebelumnya, ini
bukan satu-satunya cara algoritma mungkin digunakan tapi ini adalah cara alami untuk menerapkannya pada masalah pencarian. Selanjutnya kita akan melihat apa operasi Grover
sebenarnya lakukan pada keadaan dari N qubit yang ditindakinya. Mari kita pikirkan n qubit kita sebagai
membentuk satu register yang akan saya beri nama Q hanya untuk memilih nama. Ingat bahwa yang pertama kita lakukan dalam
algoritma Grover adalah menempatkan Q ke dalam superposisi uniform dari semua string n-bit, dan kita melakukan itu dengan menerapkan Hadamard
gate ke n qubit dalam keadaan all-zero. Kemudian kita mengiterasi operasi Grover G dan kemudian
mengukur. Akan membantu untuk membagi himpunan semua string n-bit menjadi dua himpunan A nol dan
A satu. A nol berisi semua string yang menyebabkan f mengevaluasi ke nol dan A satu berisi semua string yang menyebabkan f
mengevaluasi ke satu. Cara lain untuk mengatakannya adalah A satu berisi semua solusi untuk masalah pencarian
kita sementara A nol berisi semua non-solusi. Kita akan sangat
tertarik pada dua keadaan kuantum: satu adalah superposisi uniform atas semua non-solusi, yaitu ket A nol, dan
yang lain adalah uniform atas semua solusi dan itu adalah ket A satu. Saya harus menunjukkan bahwa definisi-definisi ini hanya masuk akal
ketika himpunan-himpunan ini tidak kosong karena jika tidak kita menjumlahkan nol hal dan membagi dengan nol. Dan saat kita menjalani
analisis algoritma Grover ini kita memang akan membuat asumsi itu. Kita bisa dengan sangat mudah mengetahui apa yang
algoritma Grover lakukan ketika f adalah fungsi konstanta nol atau fungsi konstanta satu dengan memperlakukan mereka sebagai kasus khusus, tapi saya akan meninggalkan itu
untuk kamu lakukan sendiri. Tidak mengejutkan, kalau setiap string adalah solusi kita memang akan mendapatkan
solusi ketika kita mengukur, dan kalau tidak ada solusi maka kita tidak akan mendapatkan satu karena dalam kasus itu tidak ada
satu pun. Tapi untuk keperluan analisis ini kita akan mengasumsikan bahwa kedua himpunan ini tidak kosong sehingga definisi-definisi
dari dua keadaan ini masuk akal. Omong-omong, ini adalah notasi yang cukup umum:
kapanpun kita punya himpunan berhingga non-kosong s, kita bisa menulis ket s untuk berarti superposisi uniform atas
elemen-elemen dari himpunan tersebut, seperti yang kita miliki di sini. Jadi mari kita kumpulkan definisi-definisi ini dan kita akan melihat bagaimana mereka terhubung
dengan algoritma Grover. Langkah pertama dari algoritma Grover adalah langkah inisialisasi yang menempatkan Q ke dalam superposisi uniform atas semua string n-bit,
dan hanya untuk memberi keadaan ini nama yang mudah dikenali saya akan menyebutnya
ket u. U adalah singkatan dari uniform. Penting untuk keperluan analisis bahwa pertama kita catat bahwa
keadaan uniform ket u terkandung dalam subruang yang direntangkan oleh dua vektor ket A nol dan ket
A satu. Khususnya kalau kita mengambil kombinasi linear dari dua keadaan ini yang ditampilkan di sini di layar, kita akan mendapatkan ket
u. Sekarang kunci dari seluruh analisis adalah fakta bahwa keadaan Q tetap berada dalam
subruang dua dimensi ini tidak peduli berapa kali kita menerapkan operasi Grover. Jadi segalanya akan bermuara pada
apa yang terjadi dalam subruang dua dimensi. Sekarang mari kita lihat apa yang operasi Grover lakukan dan khususnya apa yang
dilakukannya pada vektor-vektor dalam subruang dua dimensi yang direntangkan oleh ket A nol dan ket
A satu. Akan membantu untuk membayangkan bahwa G dibagi menjadi dua bagian: satu bagian adalah gate ZF
dan bagian lainnya adalah gate ZOR yang diapit di antara dua lapisan Hadamard
gate. Berikut definisi ZF dari sebelumnya, dan cukup mudah dari definisi itu untuk melihat bahwa
aksinya pada dua keadaan kita, superposisi uniform dari non-solusi dan solusi, adalah hanya meletakkan tanda minus
di depan ket A satu. Tidak ada yang terjadi pada ket A nol, dan itu semua yang perlu kita ketahui
tentang ZF untuk keperluan analisis ini. Untuk bagian kedua yang merupakan
gate ZOR yang diapit di antara dua lapisan Hadamard gate, mari mulai dengan mengingat kembali bagaimana ZOR didefinisikan. Satu cara untuk menulisnya
adalah seperti yang ditampilkan di layar. Ini adalah ekspresi yang sama seperti sebelumnya, dan cara lain untuk mengekspresikannya menggunakan notasi Dirac
adalah seperti ini. Dan kamu bisa memverifikasi ekspresi ini hanya dengan memikirkan bagaimana operasi di
sisi kanan bertindak pada keadaan basis standar. Khususnya, ia tidak melakukan apa-apa pada keadaan all-zero dan setiap
keadaan basis standar lainnya mendapat tanda minus, yang sesuai dengan definisi
ZOR. Jadi kalau kita mengapit operasi ini di antara dua lapisan Hadamard gate, kita mendapatkan ekspresi serupa kecuali
bahwa sebagai pengganti keadaan basis standar all-zero kita sekarang punya superposisi uniform kita ket u, dan itu karena H tensor
n mengubah keadaan basis standar l-zero menjadi ket u, dan juga H tensor n adalah transpos konjugatnya sendiri sehingga ia bekerja dengan cara serupa
bertindak dari kanan pada bra daripada ket. Dan sekarang kita akan mengetahui
apa yang G lakukan pada dua vektor kita A nol dan A satu menggunakan fakta-fakta yang baru saja
kita amati. Mari mulai dengan A nol terlebih dahulu. Mari kita substitusikan ekspresi
yang kita peroleh untuk gate ZOR yang diapit di antara dua lapisan Hadamard gate. Selanjutnya kita bisa menggunakan fakta bahwa ZF tidak melakukan apa-apa
WEBVTT
pada ket A nol sehingga kita bisa menghilangkan operasi ZF. Dan sekarang menggunakan deskripsi
dari ket u yang kita miliki di sini bersama dengan fakta bahwa ket A nol dan ket A satu adalah vektor unit yang ortogonal, kita bisa menghitung
hasil kali dari bra ini dan ket ini, dan yang kita dapatkan adalah akar kuadrat dari jumlah non-solusi
dibagi n. Kita bisa menggunakan fakta ini untuk mengevaluasi apa yang kita dapatkan dan dengan mensubstitusikan ekspresi kita untuk ket u dan
menyederhanakan kita mendapatkan hasil akhir yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. Khususnya perhatikan bahwa
vektor ini terkandung dalam subruang dua dimensi yang direntangkan oleh ket A nol dan ket A satu seperti yang saya sarankan sebelumnya, dan
selain itu koefisiennya kebetulan adalah bilangan real. Seperti biasa, verifikasi ini dengan
kecepatan kamu sendiri kalau kamu mau. Saya cenderung membahas hal-hal semacam ini dengan cepat dalam video-video ini dengan
harapan bahwa kamu akan menjeda video untuk memikirkannya kalau kamu mau. Jadi mari kita bersihkan ini sehingga
kita bisa menyimpan hasil akhir untuk nanti. Dan sekarang kita akan melakukan hal yang serupa untuk vektor ket
A satu. Kita bisa menggunakan ekspresi yang sama dari G seperti sebelumnya, dan kali ini gate ZF menyuntikkan
tanda minus yang di sini tercermin oleh fakta bahwa kita sudah menukar dua suku dalam operasi dalam
tanda kurung. Kita kemudian melanjutkan dengan cara yang sangat mirip dan hasil akhirnya serupa kecuali bahwa dua koefisien
ditukar dan kita sekarang punya tanda minus di depan salah satunya, yang hanya merupakan cara aljabranya bekerja. Dan sekali lagi kamu
bisa memeriksa ini dengan kecepatan kamu sendiri. Perhatikan bahwa sekali lagi kita punya kombinasi linear real dari dua vektor kita ket A nol dan
ket A satu. Kita akan membersihkan yang ini juga dan kita akan menyatukan hasil akhirnya dengan yang lain, dan sekarang kita bisa melihat bagaimana G
bertindak pada subruang yang direntangkan oleh dua vektor kita. Satu cara untuk melakukan itu adalah dengan mengekspresikannya dalam hal matriks 2x2 M yang
ditampilkan di sini di layar. Dan hanya untuk memperjelas apa yang kita lakukan di sini: kita mengasosiasikan baris pertama dan
kolom pertama dengan ket A nol dan baris dan kolom kedua dengan ket A satu. Sejauh ini dalam seri kita
benar-benar hanya menggunakan matriks untuk mendeskripsikan cara operasi bekerja pada keadaan basis standar. Tapi memang umum untuk menggunakan matriks
untuk mendeskripsikan aksi dari peta linear pada set vektor yang berbeda, bukan hanya keadaan basis standar. Dan di sini kita membicarakan apa yang operasi G lakukan
pada vektor-vektor ket A nol dan ket A satu. Kita bisa mengatakan lebih banyak tentang apa yang G lakukan pada vektor-vektor dalam
rentang dari ket A nol dan ket A satu kalau kita melihat lebih dekat matriks M ini. Dan khususnya yang akan kita temukan adalah
bahwa M adalah matriks rotasi, yang berarti aksinya pada ruang dua dimensi ini bisa dideskripsikan sebagai rotasi dengan sudut
tetap tertentu. Ada beberapa cara berbeda untuk melihat ini dan salah satunya adalah dengan mengamati
bahwa matriks M ini bisa diekspresikan sebagai kuadrat dari matriks yang terlihat agak lebih sederhana. Itu mungkin sulit untuk dilihat kalau
kita hanya melihat M dengan sendirinya, tapi ini bukanlah sesuatu yang perlu kita temukan sendiri — kita hanya perlu memverifikasinya dan kita bisa melakukan itu dengan hanya
mengkuadratkan matriks di sebelah kanan. Cara lain untuk menulis matriks di sebelah kanan tidak termasuk kuadratnya adalah
yang ditampilkan di layar, dan ini adalah cara umum untuk mendeskripsikan rotasi dengan sudut tertentu theta sebagai
matriks. Sudut tepat yang kita gunakan untuk melakukan rotasi ternyata adalah arcsine dari akar kuadrat dari jumlah
solusi dibagi n. Dan omong-omong karena ini adalah pertama kalinya kita melihatnya, izinkan saya menunjukkan bahwa
sudut ini sangat penting. Ini akan terus muncul saat kita melanjutkan dengan
analisis ini. Argumen dari arcsine adalah bilangan antara 0 dan 1, dan secara khusus cara kita
menginterpretasikan arcsine di sini adalah bahwa itu adalah sudut antara 0 dan pi dibagi 2 yang memberi kita argumen ketika kita mengambil
sinenya. Jadi itulah satu cara untuk memikirkan matriks yang kita kuadratkan untuk mendapatkan
M. Dan karena mengkuadratkan matriks sama dengan menerapkannya dua kali, kita melihat bahwa M bisa alternatifnya ditulis sebagai
rotasi bukan dengan sudut theta tapi dengan 2 kali theta, karena dengan mengkuadratkan kita memutar dengan sudut theta
dua kali. Cara berbeda untuk memverifikasi semua ini omong-omong kalau itu membantu adalah dengan memulai dengan ekspresi akhir dari M
ini dan menggunakan rumus sudut ganda dari trigonometri untuk mendapatkan ekspresi asli dari
M. Dan inilah ekspresi dari M yang mendeskripsikan aksi yang dimiliki g pada subruang yang direntangkan oleh ket A nol dan ket A satu yang
akan paling berguna ke depannya. Sekarang kembali ke algoritma Grover sendiri setelah
langkah inisialisasi tapi sebelum kita melakukan aplikasi G manapun, keadaan dari register N qubit kita Q adalah ket u,
superposisi uniform atas semua string n-bit. Dan di sini kita punya ekspresi yang sama dari ket u dalam hal ket A nol dan
ket A satu seperti sebelumnya. Tapi sekarang karena kita sudah mengidentifikasi sudut theta ini, kita melihat bahwa kita
bisa alternatifnya menulis ket u sebagai kosinus theta kali ket A nol ditambah sinus theta kali ket
A satu. Itu jelas untuk koefisien dari ket A satu, dan untuk koefisien lainnya kita hanya perlu mengamati bahwa ukuran A nol ditambah
ukuran A satu adalah n, dan kemudian kita bisa mendapatkannya dari trigonometri dasar. Jadi itulah keadaan yang kita
mulai, dan pertama kali kita menerapkan G kita memutar dengan sudut 2 kali theta sehingga sudut total menjadi 3 kali
theta. Dan kalau kita menerapkan G lagi sudutnya meningkat ke 5 theta karena kita telah secara efektif memutar dengan
tambahan sudut 2 theta. Dan seterusnya. Jadi setelah T aplikasi G kita bisa merepresentasikan
keadaan yang kita dapatkan seperti yang ditampilkan di layar di mana sudut keadaan kita sama dengan (2T + 1) kali theta. Itu 2 kali theta
untuk setiap aplikasi G bersama dengan theta tambahan karena itulah keadaan yang kita mulai.
Kita juga bisa memikirkan aksi dari operasi Grover dalam istilah geometris dan ini membantu untuk menjelaskan bagaimana
ia bekerja dan mengapa efeknya adalah memutar keadaan register Q. Berikut ide utamanya. Operasi Grover
adalah komposisi dari dua bagian yang sudah kita identifikasi. Satu adalah ZF dan yang lainnya adalah ZOR yang diapit di antara
dua lapisan Hadamard gate. Kedua bagian ini adalah
refleksi, dan ketika kita menyusun dua refleksi kita mendapatkan rotasi. Jadi mari kita lihat bagaimana ini bekerja dengan
lebih detail. Pertama mari kita fokus pada ZF dan kita akan membatasi perhatian kita pada
subruang dua dimensi yang sama yang sudah kita bicarakan, yaitu yang direntangkan oleh ket A nol dan ket
A satu. Seperti yang sudah kita amati, aksi dari ZF pada ruang ini cukup sederhana — ia tidak melakukan apa-apa
pada ket A nol dan meletakkan tanda minus di depan ket A satu. Ini adalah refleksi dan khususnya
WEBVTT
ini adalah refleksi tentang garis yang sejajar dengan ket A nol yang akan kita sebut L1 hanya untuk memberinya
nama. Untuk melihat mengapa ini adalah refleksi, akan membantu untuk menggambar sebuah gambar. Di sini kita punya dua vektor ket
A nol dan ket A satu yang merupakan vektor unit yang ortogonal, dan kita bisa memikirkan layar sebagai terdiri dari semua
kombinasi linear real dari dua vektor ini. Jadi lingkaran merepresentasikan semua vektor unit yang koefisiennya dari
dua vektor ini adalah bilangan real. Berikut garis L1 yang sejajar dengan ket A nol, dan kalau kita pertimbangkan beberapa
vektor sembarang s pada lingkaran ini, maka efek dari menerapkan ZF adalah merefleksikan tentang garis ini seperti yang diilustrasikan di
layar, hanya karena kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada ket A nol dan kita meletakkan tanda minus di depan ket
A satu. Dalam kasus khusus bahwa s adalah ket A nol misalnya, tidak ada yang terjadi ketika kita melakukan refleksi ini, dan ketika s adalah
ket A satu, refleksi membawa kita semua jalan ke negatif ket A satu, dan itu konsisten dengan aksi dari ZF. Jadi ZF adalah
refleksi yang bisa divisualisasikan seperti yang kita miliki di sini. Bagian kedua dari G yang merupakan ZOR
yang diapit di antara dua lapisan Hadamard gate bisa diekspresikan sebagai 2 kali ket u bra u minus matriks identitas seperti yang sudah
kita lihat sebelumnya, dan sekali lagi ini adalah refleksi — kali ini tentang garis L2 yang sejajar dengan ket u daripada ket
A nol. Kita bisa memvisualisasikan operasi ini dengan cara yang mirip dengan ZF. Berikut vektor ket
u secara hipotetis, jadi inilah garis L2 yang sejajar dengan ket u, dan sekali lagi aksi pada vektor sembarang s adalah merefleksikannya
tentang garis yang adalah L2 dalam kasus ini.
Dan akhirnya seperti yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya, kapanpun kita menyusun dua refleksi kita mendapatkan rotasi, dan secara khusus itu adalah
rotasi dengan dua kali sudut antara garis-garis refleksi. Jadi mari kita gambarkan
gambar yang mirip dengan yang kita miliki sebelumnya. Berikut garis-garis refleksi yang memiliki sudut theta di antara
mereka. Dan kalau kita mengambil beberapa vektor sembarang s yang direfleksikan di sekitar garis pertama L1 dan
kemudian direfleksikan tentang garis kedua L2, maka efek bersihnya adalah memutar vektor s dengan sudut dua kali theta.
Dan ini adalah sesuatu yang berlaku secara umum dan kamu bisa mencobanya pada beberapa contoh tambahan sendiri untuk melihat bahwa inilah cara kerjanya.
Bagaimanapun semoga ini membantu kamu mendapatkan intuisi mengapa operasi Grover memiliki efek memutar
vektor-vektor. Selanjutnya kita akan beralih ke masalah pemilihan jumlah iterasi T dalam algoritma
Grover. Mari mulai dengan memikirkan bagaimana analisis yang sudah kita lihat sejauh ini yang mengungkapkan apa yang operasi Grover lakukan
ketika kita menerapkannya berulang kali pada superposisi uniform berhubungan dengan tugas yang kita harapkan untuk diselesaikan, yaitu menemukan solusi untuk masalah pencarian kita
atau dengan kata lain string apapun yang terkandung dalam himpunan A satu. Singkatnya, kita pada dasarnya akan menetapkan
target dan kemudian mengetahui berapa kali menerapkan operasi Grover untuk mendekati
target tersebut. Pertama mari kita bayangkan bahwa kita punya keadaan apapun yang merupakan kombinasi linear dari dua vektor kita ket A nol dan ket
A satu. Kalau kita melakukan pengukuran basis standar pada keadaan ini, kita akan mendapatkan hasil dalam himpunan A satu yang
merupakan himpunan solusi untuk masalah pencarian kita dengan probabilitas yang sama dengan kuadrat dari nilai mutlak dari koefisien yang kita miliki untuk ket A satu. Dan untuk
vektor yang ditampilkan di layar, koefisien itu adalah beta. Ini intuitif — kalau kita mengukur keadaan ket A nol
kita akan mendapat non-solusi acak, dan kalau kita mengukur ket A satu kita akan mendapat solusi acak. Jadi kalau kita mengukur keadaan ini
di sini kita akan mendapat non-solusi acak dengan probabilitas nilai mutlak dari alpha kuadrat dan solusi acak
dengan probabilitas nilai mutlak dari beta kuadrat. Tapi kita juga bisa hanya meluangkan waktu untuk mengerjakannya. Berikut keadaan yang ditulis
sehingga kita bisa melihat apa entri-entri dari vektor ini untuk keadaan basis standar. Jadi kalau kita mengukur, ini adalah probabilitas
untuk mendapatkan setiap kemungkinan hasil, dan untuk mendapatkan probabilitas untuk mendapatkan solusi kita menjumlahkan
probabilitas untuk semua kemungkinan solusi yang memberi kita nilai mutlak dari beta kuadrat seperti
yang diharapkan. Sekarang kita sudah menganalisis apa yang terjadi ketika kita menjalankan algoritma Grover untuk T iterasi — kita mendapatkan keadaan yang
ditampilkan di sini di layar. Jadi karena koefisien dari ket A satu adalah sinus
dari (2T + 1) kali theta — di mana sekali lagi inilah sudut theta yang sangat penting ini — kita
akan melihat solusi dengan probabilitas sinus kuadrat dari (2T + 1) kali
theta. Kita ingin membuat probabilitas itu besar, idealnya sedekat satu mungkin. Jadi saat kita memutar vektor keadaan
dengan mengiterasi G, kita akan memikirkan ket A satu sebagai keadaan target dan kita akan mencoba
memilih T sehingga kita mendarat dekat keadaan ini. Dan saat kita melakukan ini ada baiknya untuk mengingat bahwa kita juga ingin
meminimalkan T karena itulah jumlah query yang perlu kita lakukan. Jadi kalau kita ingin membuat probabilitas ini
mendekati satu dan meminimalkan T, masuk akal untuk mencoba membuat sudut dari vektor keadaan kita dekat dengan pi dibagi 2 karena
itulah sudut terkecil yang membuat kuadrat dari sinus besar. Jadi ini pada dasarnya adalah kesempatan pertama kita untuk membuat probabilitas besar saat kita memutar
vektor keadaan. Sekarang kita tidak selalu bisa mencapai sudut pi dibagi 2 ini secara tepat karena T harus
berupa bilangan bulat. Tapi kalau kita memikirkannya secara perkiraan dan memecahkan T seolah-olah itu adalah pertidaksamaan, maka kita melihat bahwa idealnya
memilih T menjadi pi dibagi 4 dikali theta minus setengah
masuk akal. Tapi tentu saja T harus berupa bilangan bulat non-negatif, jadi yang akan kita lakukan adalah mengambil
bilangan bulat yang paling dekat dengan nilai ideal yang kita bayangkan ini, yaitu lantai dari pi dibagi 4 dikali
theta. Mengambil lantai omong-omong hanya berarti kita membuang bagian fraksional manapun, jadi dengan kata lain itu adalah bilangan bulat terbesar
yang kurang dari atau sama dengan apapun yang kita ambil lantainya. Menurut ekspresi ini kalau nilai ideal kebetulan ada di tengah antara bilangan bulat, kita akan membulatkan ke atas, tapi itu sebenarnya tidak akan berpengaruh sama sekali untuk
keperluan pelajaran ini. Jadi ke depannya kita akan fokus pada pilihan T
yang khusus ini. Tapi ada satu pertimbangan penting lain yang perlu kita buat, yaitu spesifikasi T ini bergantung
pada berapa banyak solusi yang ada karena sudut theta bergantung pada jumlah
solusi. Mulai sekarang saya akan menggunakan huruf s untuk merujuk pada jumlah solusi, atau dengan kata lain ukuran dari
himpunan A satu, hanya untuk kenyamanan. Bagaimanapun juga, intinya adalah bahwa
ekspresi kita untuk T — nilai yang kita hipotesiskan harus bagus — bergantung pada theta, dan theta bergantung pada s yang adalah
WEBVTT
ukuran dari himpunan A satu. Ini bukan masalah kalau kita tahu sebelumnya berapa banyak solusi yang ada, tapi
kalau kita tidak tahu sebelumnya berapa banyak solusi yang ada, kita tidak tahu apa itu theta sehingga kita tidak bisa memilih T seperti ini
dan kita harus melakukan sesuatu yang berbeda. Saya akan kembali ke situasi di mana kita tidak tahu s sedikit kemudian, tapi untuk
sekarang mari kita fokus pada situasi di mana kita memang tahu berapa banyak solusi yang ada, dimulai dengan unique search
di mana ada jaminan bahwa ada satu solusi unik yang kita cari.
Saya menyebutkan masalah unique search sebagai contoh dari masalah query kembali di pelajaran
lima. Input adalah fungsi f dari n bit ke satu bit. Ada n-bit string unik
yang menyebabkan f mengevaluasi ke satu, dan tujuannya adalah mengeluarkan string tersebut. Jadi
ini setara dengan masalah unstructured search yang sudah kita bicarakan tapi dengan janji bahwa ada tepat satu solusi. Dan sebenarnya ini adalah
satu-satunya versi dari masalah pencarian yang dipertimbangkan Lov Grover dalam makalah aslinya tahun 1996 yang memperkenalkan algoritma
Grover. Untuk unique search kita punya s sama dengan 1, dan karenanya sudut penting theta ini sama dengan arcsine
dari akar kuadrat dari 1/n. Ketika n besar, nilai ini kira-kira sama dengan akar kuadrat dari 1/n dan
itu karena untuk sudut yang semakin kecil, fungsi sinus mulai terlihat semakin mirip dengan fungsi identitas.
Kalau kita mensubstitusikan perkiraan itu ke dalam pilihan T kita, kita melihat bahwa T kira-kira adalah lantai
dari pi dibagi 4 dikali akar kuadrat dari n. Itu bagus karena kita sedang menuju penggunaan O besar dari akar kuadrat dari n
query, meski pada titik ini kita belum melihat tepat seberapa baik algoritmanya
bekerja. Mari kita lihat sebuah contoh di mana N kapital adalah 128 yang adalah 2 pangkat 7. Jadi
fungsi f kita adalah dari tujuh bit ke satu bit dan kita mengasumsikan ada solusi unik. Tapi untuk mengetahui seberapa
baik algoritma bekerja kita sebenarnya hanya perlu memperhatikan sudut theta yang bisa kita hitung.
Ini kira-kira 0.0885 radian yang sedikit lebih dari 5 derajat. Dan kalau kita memasukkan nilai itu ke dalam
ekspresi kita untuk T kita mendapatkan delapan. Jadi kita memikirkan apa yang terjadi ketika kita mencari solusi unik dari 128
kemungkinan menggunakan delapan query. Kita bisa menggambar sebuah gambar untuk mengilustrasikan bagaimana keadaan berubah dari waktu ke waktu
saat kita melakukan iterasi dari operasi Grover. Seperti sebelumnya kita punya keadaan-keadaan ket
A nol dan ket A satu, dan dalam kasus khusus ini yaitu unique search kita punya bahwa ket A satu sebenarnya adalah keadaan basis standar
yang berkoresponden dengan solusi unik apapun itu. Sementara ket A nol adalah superposisi uniform atas semua
string selain solusi unik. Berikut superposisi uniform atas semua string yang bisa
kita tulis sebagai kosinus theta ket A nol ditambah sinus theta ket A satu, dan masuk akal bahwa ket A nol
dan ket u dekat dalam kasus ini karena seperti yang baru saja kita amati sebentar lalu, ket A nol adalah
hampir superposisi uniform atas semua string — hanya ada satu string yang hilang dan itu adalah solusi unik. Menerapkan G lagi memutar dengan
tambahan 2 theta, jadi inilah kita setelah dua iterasi. Berikut tiga, empat, lima, enam, tujuh, dan delapan.
Dan sekarang kita melihat bahwa kita cukup dekat dengan ket A satu. Jadi kalau kita berhenti dan mengukur pada titik ini kita cukup mungkin untuk mendapatkan
solusi unik. Dan sebenarnya dalam kasus ini hanya ada sekitar setengah persen kemungkinan bahwa kita tidak mendapatkan solusi unik.
Di sisi lain, kalau kita terus menerapkan operasi Grover lebih dari delapan kali yang direkomendasikan,
maka probabilitas untuk mendapatkan solusi akan turun kembali dan seiring waktu akan berosilasi saat keadaan berputar
mengelilingi lingkaran. Jadi penting bahwa kita menghentikan iterasi pada waktu yang tepat kalau kita ingin berhasil dengan probabilitas tinggi.
Mari pikirkan tentang probabilitas bahwa pilihan T kita mengungkapkan solusi unik secara lebih umum untuk nilai-nilai n yang berbeda.
Kita akan menulis p(n,1) untuk menunjukkan probabilitas bahwa algoritma Grover berhasil menemukan solusi unik
untuk setiap nilai n yang mungkin. Satu berarti satu solusi dan kita akan memperluas notasi ini ke jumlah solusi lainnya
segera. Berikut tabel probabilitas-probabilitas ini untuk pangkat dua yang kecil. Ini dimulai dengan n sama dengan 2 dan
probabilitasnya adalah 1/2 yang tidak terlalu bagus. Tapi kemudian untuk n sama dengan 4 probabilitasnya adalah tepat satu sehingga sebenarnya bekerja
dengan sempurna dalam kasus ini. Ini adalah latihan yang bagus omong-omong untuk secara eksplisit menjalani bagaimana dua kasus ini bekerja,
terutama kasus di mana n sama dengan empat. Dalam kasus itu kita mencari satu solusi dari empat kemungkinan,
kita hanya butuh satu query dan itu bekerja dengan sempurna. Seiring n bertambah besar kita memang melihat beberapa fluktuasi. Probabilitas naik
dan turun sedikit, tapi tampaknya semakin mendekati satu, dan memang itu benar. Bisa dibuktikan
secara analitis bahwa probabilitasnya selalu setidaknya 1 - 1/n. Jadi itu bagus.
Algoritmanya tidak sempurna — kita tidak dijamin mendapatkan solusi — tapi ini cukup mungkin terutama untuk nilai-nilai n yang besar,
serta anomali yang sangat menarik yang terjadi ketika n sama dengan 4.
Saya juga harus menunjukkan bahwa kita selalu bisa menjalankan seluruh algoritma termasuk pengukuran sebanyak yang kita pilih dan kalau salah satu dari jalannya
berhasil kita akan mendapatkan solusi. Jadi kalau probabilitas-probabilitas ini tidak cukup baik kita bisa dengan mudah meningkatkannya dengan hanya menjalankan
algoritma lagi. Sebenarnya bahkan kalau probabilitas-probabilitas ini semua sama dengan 1/2 misalnya, kita masih akan punya
algoritma pencarian yang berguna. Sekarang mari pertimbangkan apa yang terjadi ketika ada beberapa
solusi. Kita akan mulai dengan contoh yang mirip dengan sebelumnya. Sekali lagi n sama dengan 128 tapi kali ini jumlah
solusi s adalah empat daripada satu. Sekali lagi kita bisa menghitung theta dan T dan
kita mendapatkan bahwa theta kira-kira 0.1777 atau sedikit lebih dari 10 derajat dan T adalah
empat kali ini. Jadi sudutnya kira-kira dua kali nilai dari contoh sebelumnya dan T adalah separuh dari apa yang itu
tadi. Kita bisa menggambar gambar seperti sebelumnya. Berikut di mana kita
mulai. Berikut satu iterasi, dua, tiga, dan empat. Kali ini kita sangat dekat dengan ket
A satu dan probabilitas untuk mendapatkan solusi kali ini ternyata lebih dari
99,9%. Tapi kalau kita tidak tahu lebih baik dan kita pikir hanya ada satu solusi, kita akan mengambil T menjadi 8 seperti
sebelumnya. Kita akan memutar hampir sepanjang jalan ke negatif ket A nol dan itu akan menyebabkan probabilitas keberhasilan yang sangat kecil.
Jadi itulah contoh lebih lanjut yang menunjukkan bahwa ada pilihan T yang baik dan pilihan T yang buruk, dan di sini kita melihat
WEBVTT
bahwa pilihan yang baik untuk s sama dengan 1 ternyata menjadi pilihan yang sangat buruk untuk s sama dengan 4. Tapi dengan asumsi kita memang tahu s
sebelumnya dan kita memilih T sesuai dengan spesifikasi kita, maka ternyata algoritma Grover akan menemukan solusi
dengan probabilitas setidaknya 1 - s/n dan seringkali jauh lebih besar dari itu. Ini juga setidaknya s/n tapi
itu sebenarnya jauh kurang menarik. Yang lebih menarik adalah saat fraksi s/n menjadi kecil, batas
pada probabilitas keberhasilan semakin dekat dan semakin dekat ke satu. Sekarang seperti yang sudah saya sebutkan beberapa
kali, angka T merepresentasikan bukan hanya jumlah iterasi dari operasi Grover yang kita lakukan, tapi juga jumlah
query yang kita buat. Jadi bagaimana angka ini bergantung pada s dan
n? Pertama mari mulai dengan fakta bahwa arcsine dari x selalu setidaknya x asalkan x antara nol dan 1.
Itu cukup mudah untuk ditunjukkan kalau kamu kebetulan mengetahui deret Taylor untuk fungsi arcsine, tapi ada cara lain untuk mempertimbangkannya dan kita hanya
akan mengambilnya sebagai yang diberikan karena itu benar. Itu berarti theta setidaknya akar kuadrat dari s/
n dan akibatnya T paling banyak pi dibagi 4 dikali akar kuadrat dari n/
s. Jadi itu sebenarnya bahkan lebih baik dari O besar dari akar n. Semakin besar s adalah dalam
perbandingan dengan n, semakin sedikit query yang perlu kita buat. Dan dalam beberapa hal tidak mengejutkan bahwa fraksi ini muncul
seperti ini mengingat bahwa kebalikannya mendefinisikan theta dan pada akhirnya theta adalah satu-satunya yang penting untuk
analisis ini. Seperti yang baru saja kita lihat, algoritma Grover bekerja dengan sangat baik ketika kita tahu
sebelumnya berapa banyak solusi yang ada. Tapi bagaimana kalau kita tidak tahu berapa banyak solusi yang
ada? Ada satu pendekatan yang cukup sederhana dan itu adalah hanya memilih jumlah iterasi
secara acak. Secara khusus, memilih T secara uniform acak antara satu dan lantai dari pi dibagi 4 dikali akar n ternyata
merupakan cara yang cukup baik untuk melakukan ini. Batas atas dari rentang ini kira-kira adalah jumlah query yang kita pilih untuk unique search, dan sebenarnya
itu adalah jumlah yang tepat dalam kebanyakan kasus. Ini adalah saat sudut theta sekecil yang mungkin, tidak termasuk
kasus sepele saat tidak ada solusi. Idenya di sini adalah bahwa daripada dengan hati-hati mengarahkan vektor keadaan kita ke
ket A satu seperti yang kita lakukan ketika kita tahu berapa banyak solusi yang ada, kita pada dasarnya memutar dengan sudut acak seolah-olah kita
hanya memberi vektor keadaan putaran acak. Kalau kebetulan hanya ada satu solusi, maka putaran acak kita bisa mendorong
vektor keadaan mendekati ket A satu tapi mungkin juga hanya sebagian menuju ke sana. Dan kalau kebetulan ada banyak solusi maka
putaran acak kita berpotensi mengirim vektor keadaan mengelilingi lingkaran beberapa kali. Jadi kita tidak berharap ini mengungkapkan
solusi dengan probabilitas yang mendekati satu, tapi kesempatan ini mengarah pada solusi jika ada satu ternyata cukup
bagus. Ini selalu setidaknya 40% sebenarnya. Itu tidak jelas tapi memang
demikian. Tentu saja itu tidak mengejutkan karena sudut yang benar-benar acak akan memiliki kesempatan 50% untuk menemukan
solusi. Bagaimanapun juga, 40% tidak buruk, dan ingat bahwa kita selalu bisa meningkatkan probabilitas menemukan solusi dengan
mengulangi prosesnya, memilih T secara independen setiap kali. Dengan melakukan ini kesempatan tidak menemukan
solusi ketika ada satu berkurang secara eksponensial dalam jumlah kali kita mengulangi. Jadi kalau kita ingin kesempatan 99%
untuk menemukan solusi, yang bisa kita lakukan adalah menjalankan pendekatan sederhana ini 10 kali lagi dengan T yang dipilih secara independen setiap kali.
Secara alami kalau kita tidak menemukan solusi kita mengeluarkan tidak ada solusi. Kalau tidak ada solusi
kita tidak akan menemukan satu dan jadi dalam kasus itu kita akan selalu mengeluarkan jawaban yang benar yaitu tidak ada solusi. Kalau ada solusi kita
mungkin gagal menemukan satu dan salah menyatakan bahwa tidak ada solusi, tapi probabilitas hal itu terjadi bisa dibuat sangat kecil.
Kita juga punya seperti yang saya sebutkan beberapa momen lalu bahwa ini memerlukan jumlah query atau evaluasi dari f yang adalah O besar dari akar
n. Jadi menggunakan algoritma Grover kita masih bisa memecahkan masalah pencarian dengan probabilitas tinggi dengan O besar dari akar n
query bahkan kalau kita tidak tahu sebelumnya berapa banyak solusi yang ada. Ada juga pendekatan yang lebih canggih
yang bisa mengarah pada pengurangan jumlah query seiring jumlah solusi bertumbuh. Saya tidak akan mendeskripsikannya secara
detail dan sebaliknya saya akan hanya fokus pada ide utama. Kita mulai dengan T kapital sama dengan
satu. Kemudian kita menjalankan algoritma Grover untuk jumlah iterasi acak tapi di mana batas atasnya adalah T. Jadi yang pertama
kali kita sampai ke langkah dua kita akan menjalankan algoritma Grover dengan satu iterasi, tapi T akan
bertumbuh. Kalau kita menemukan solusi maka kita mengeluarkan solusi tersebut dan berhenti. Dan kalau kita tidak menemukan solusi kita membuat T
lebih besar dan mencoba lagi. Dan pada suatu titik sebelum T menjadi terlalu besar kita akan mengakhiri proses dan
menyatakan bahwa tidak ada solusi. Ini adalah ide dasar yang sama seperti yang kita miliki dalam pendekatan sederhana di mana kita pada dasarnya
memberikan putaran acak pada vektor keadaan, tapi di sini kita mulai dengan putaran yang lebih ringan terlebih dahulu di mana T adalah
kecil, kalau-kalau ada banyak solusi. Dengan cara ini kita tidak akan membuang query dengan membuat keadaan berputar
mengelilingi lingkaran dengan memutar terlalu keras. Tapi kalau tidak berhasil artinya kita tidak menemukan solusi, kita coba lagi
tapi kita memutar sedikit lebih keras atau mungkin sedikit lebih keras. Untuk membuat ini bekerja, laju
peningkatan T harus dipilih dengan hati-hati dan satu cara untuk membuatnya bekerja adalah mengganti T dengan plafon dari 5/4 kali T.
Jadi T sedang ditingkatkan secara eksponensial dan secara intuitif kita bisa memikirkannya sebagai memutar 25% lebih keras setiap
kali. Dan penting untuk analisis bahwa T meningkat secara eksponensial seperti ini. Mengapa 5/4 mungkin kamu tanya? Nah, itu
hanya angka yang berhasil dan sebenarnya ada rentang nilai yang berhasil, tapi dua misalnya tidak berhasil. Menggandakan T
setiap kali adalah peningkatan yang terlalu cepat untuk memanfaatkan sepenuhnya manfaat dari putaran yang lebih ringan. Bagaimanapun juga, intinya dari metode yang lebih
canggih ini adalah bahwa ia memberikan batas asimtotik yang sama pada jumlah query yang kita butuhkan seperti yang kita miliki sebelumnya:
O besar dari akar kuadrat dari n/s. Tapi kita tidak perlu tahu sebelumnya berapa banyak solusi yang ada. Dan omong-omong,
kita bisa menghentikan proses ini ketika T mencapai akar n. Jadi kalau tidak ada solusi kita akan mencapai kesimpulan tersebut setelah O besar
dari akar n query. Dan begitulah kita bisa memilih jumlah iterasi dalam algoritma Grover. Untuk menyimpulkan pelajaran, saya akan
membuat hanya beberapa catatan singkat tentang algoritma Grover. Pertama, dalam model query,
algoritma Grover adalah optimal secara asimtotik. Yang itu berarti tidak mungkin untuk membuat
algoritma query untuk memecahkan masalah pencarian atau bahkan masalah unique search secara khusus yang menggunakan secara asimtotik
WEBVTT
lebih sedikit dari O besar dari akar n query dalam kasus terburuk. Itu adalah sesuatu yang bisa dibuktikan secara ketat
dan memang ada beberapa bukti yang diketahui dari fakta ini. Menariknya, ini sudah diketahui bahkan
sebelum algoritma Grover ditemukan. Algoritma Grover cocok dengan batas bawah yang sudah diketahui tentang jumlah
query yang diperlukan. Dari waktu ke waktu orang-orang memang membuat pendekatan yang mereka yakini adalah
secara asimtotik lebih unggul dari algoritma Grover, tapi selalu ada kesalahan atau asumsi tentang fungsi f dan
bagaimana ia bisa diakses atau beberapa masalah lain yang membuat klaim tersebut tidak benar. Kalau kamu bekerja dengan benar
dalam model query, kamu tidak bisa mengalahkan algoritma Grover untuk unstructured search. Kedua, algoritma Grover adalah
cukup luas dapat diterapkan dalam artian bahwa percepatan akar kuadrat yang ditawarkan algoritma Grover untuk masalah unstructured search bisa
diperoleh dalam berbagai pengaturan yang berbeda. Misalnya, terkadang mungkin untuk menggunakan algoritma Grover di
atas algoritma lain untuk mendapatkan peningkatan kuadrat melebihi kinerja algoritma tersebut. Algoritma Grover juga
cukup umum digunakan sebagai subrutin di dalam algoritma kuantum lainnya. Sebagai satu contoh sederhana, kita
bisa menggunakan algoritma Grover untuk mendapatkan keunggulan kuadrat atas algoritma klasik untuk masalah minimum yang saya sebutkan dalam
pelajaran lima. Dan akhirnya, teknik yang digunakan dalam algoritma Grover di mana kita punya dua
refleksi yang disusun dan diiterasi untuk memutar vektor keadaan kuantum bisa digeneralisasi dengan cara yang cukup
besar. Contohnya adalah teknik yang dikenal sebagai amplitude amplification di mana sebuah proses
yang menggeneralisasi algoritma Grover bisa diterapkan ke algoritma kuantum lain untuk pada dasarnya meningkatkan probabilitas keberhasilannya secara kuadrat lebih cepat daripada
yang mungkin secara klasik, dan teknik itu memiliki aplikasi yang luas dalam algoritma kuantum. Jadi mungkin benar bahwa
algoritma Grover mungkin tidak akan mengarah pada keunggulan kuantum praktis dalam waktu dekat jika pernah, tapi algoritma Grover adalah
tanpa keraguan algoritma kuantum yang secara fundamental penting dan dapat diterapkan secara luas, dan ia merepresentasikan teknik yang lebih umum yang memiliki banyak
kegunaan. Dan itulah akhir dari pelajaran ini dan untuk unit ini dari seri yang telah membahas algoritma
kuantum. Kita mendiskusikan model query dan bagaimana kita bisa menghubungkannya dengan model komputasi yang lebih standar bersama dengan
beberapa konsep fundamental lainnya mengenai bagaimana kita bisa mengukur biaya komputasi. Kemudian kita membahas estimasi fase
dan pemfaktoran dan kemudian akhirnya algoritma Grover. Seperti yang sudah saya sarankan,
ada banyak lagi yang bisa dipelajari tentang algoritma kuantum tapi dalam seri ini kita akan beralih ke topik yang berbeda di unit berikutnya. Khususnya kita akan melihat
pada formulasi umum dari informasi kuantum di mana keadaan kuantum direpresentasikan oleh matriks dari jenis
tertentu yang dikenal sebagai density matrix. Seperti yang akan kita lihat, formulasi ini ternyata sangat berguna dan memang
sangat penting untuk memahami beberapa aspek dari informasi kuantum, dan juga kebetulan cukup indah dari
sudut pandang matematis. Jadi saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk unit tiga dan sampai jumpa lagi!